that's not the plan
I was going to ask you Jayden because
obviously uh
uh do you have any relationship or have
you ever had any sort of conversations
that were peaceful with Christian
because you guys are gonna have half
siblings uh no I don't think we've ever
had to know peaceful nothing peaceful no
I think it's always good time no it's
not even a well it's not like I don't
know what he's talking about but are you
interested I'm not interested in that at
all I'm not I'm not interested in that
at all I kind of stay they would never
cross paths I just kind of I mean I
think this is like you obviously you're
gonna have a they're gonna be half
brothers that's kind of that's kind of
more so like his dictation because like
he knows how I am with my kids that's
what it is not changing for because you
went and did that it's not changing what
I say is what I'm going with my kids I
don't know about like would you be
opposed to your kids meeting
you know his baby you know I mean maybe
under his care or my care just not that
person's just not happening but I mean I
can't really that's kind of that would
kind of be evil of me to like be like
they can never meet like I don't I I've
never had to have like a half sibling
with somebody that my mom didn't like or
something so I don't really know but
you've never had to go today yeah so I
mean but I also don't want to be the
evil Mom that's like you can't see them
like I mean he went and did that it's
like as long as he still goes with what
I am comfortable with I mean what can I
I can't really yeah like I don't really
there's not much I can do for sure you
know what I'm saying like I'm just being
real like that's just it seems like a
pretty reasonable human being I mean you
know like don't cross me but like yeah
this might annoy me like there's things
that I don't want to have to deal with
obviously that was like disappointing
but I don't I can't like sit and change
it so I'm not gonna be the evil one like
no and make it hard for him and make him
want to like do [__] that I wouldn't
like so I mean if I have to if I can
pick and choose I'll do that like do you
have any uh blue face tattoos
yeah I have uh the one on my ass and
then I have his initials right here but
you got this one too oh yeah and I have
this one you guys yeah it's a matching
tat right yeah I have this one this one
another one on my ass what's the one on
your asset it's just his uh
Jonathan Porter on it no did you got the
[__] government
license plate that's interesting
yeah the last time I did an interview
with this guy
my table got [__] up every time
[Music]
she respectful of course
I ever see that no um
I was gonna say uh For You Blue uh tell
me what's the update with your legal
situation because we've all I mean look
we've been hearing about what happened
you obviously got out quick guys I'm on
house arrest um
hopefully my next court date I could be
off house arrest if we can come to an
agreement and you know come to an
understanding and
you know
um now is the origin of all this stuff
that whatever happened at that strip
club no so I got to attempt to murder
case and that's because it's all in
Vegas yeah yeah it's on Vegas so I got
to attempted murder case
and then um
maybe like a couple days before my court
date I came out here for my court date
and then I had got into something at
this casino
where rock hit this girl and then I had
to like you know play defense and you
know it just got got carried away and
then so because of that incident they
put me on Outsource and told me I gotta
stay here wow
so all the all the the big the big the
attempted murder thing that's unresolved
yeah that's unresolved well I was still
dealing with I was still fighting and
going to court you know but once I went
to court for that case
they [__] booked me for that case
like they put like a weird warrant like
the day of right okay he's coming to
court here because like technically he
like didn't wasn't doing what they asked
of him to do the few days before so I
was gonna say so like when you got
picked up a couple weeks ago what was
was it a probation violation no it was
for the for the [__] at the casino for
that but he came out here for that he
probably should have just came out here
okay some civil right at the casino
so the next court date they like they
put a warrant that day yeah right
because what I did wasn't enough for
them to like Grant a real warrant go to
California and get me for me right right
right right have you decided uh whenever
this all gets resolved you're gonna just
leave Vegas alone
just go to the Morongo bro we just like
never need to come back if you want to
gamble just go to Paul yeah that's what
I said right I like Bob's Rings like
every time you're in Vegas it's just bad
I only want to gamble no more I just
want to sit at home and make money all
right I don't want to go outside I want
to go to no bar no club or nothing I
just want to sit at home yo I mean you
guys you've always been dropping um
I mean you dropped the record where you
were in the jet ski in the pool was it
called smile didn't have been having
okay um
how I mean you don't seem
too focused on putting out like a new
album or anything I mean you're just
dropping here and there but I don't know
I'm just
like I said at this point in my career I
want to get money with my significant
other right you know that's what I want
to do I don't want to get my significant
other
um
yeah yeah others you know whoever wants
to be my kid you know like I said I did
it for myself already yeah so it's like
look I did it for myself
I did it for right
nothing to do it's like I'm just
reassuring myself you know yeah as
time's going on